tonight at the Palazzo Ballroom in the  Venetian the Republican Jewish Coalition  gathering for their annual leadership  meeting major Republican congressmen and  governors in attendance as well as  former vice president Mike Pence who  gave a speech here is a clip of that  speech describing a milestone from the  Trump Administration  when on the south lawn of the White  House leaders of Israel Bahrain and the  UAE gathered and signed the first peace  agreement in the Middle East in nearly  30 years  [Applause]  and that was the leadership that RJC  made possible  the leadership conference resumes  tomorrow where Donald Trump is scheduled  for an appearance via Zoom Florida  Governor Ron DeSantis also set to appear  this weekend